what would Battlefield nuclear weapons
look like like what's an example of one
and how would it play out uh sure well a
battlefield nuclear weapon I
distinguished between Battlefield use
theater use which is more like a longer
range strike and to for example the
Eastern uh parts of the Ukraine near the
border of Poland for example but
Battlefield use is limited to attacking
other combat troops it's probably going
to be an air burst not a ground
detonation they don't want the Fallout
coming into the Russian territory but
you can do a low yield it could be less
than a kiloton you know for example
Hiroshima is about 15 kiloton it could
be a one kiloton it could be less than a
kiloton we gave up we unilaterally
dismantled and destroyed our tactical
Battlefield nuclear weapons back in 1991
the first George Bush president it got
nothing in return Russia kept theirs
China's kept and expanded and modernized
air they still have them so they could
absolutely annihilate Ukrainian Ground
Forces
the why isn't he why is Putin not yet
using low yield nukes to just clear the
field and take the land uh because he
hasn't been in a desperate enough
situation thus far once you do that you
know it's it's
it is an escalation there is a risk that
you know uh potentially you know we'll
I'll give you one example once this
happens and he gets away with it I think
he would get away with it the US is not
going to respond with the nuclear attack
on Russia if they do a nuclear
detonation in Ukraine that would be
insane for President Biden to do he
would not do that so if they do that and
he gets away with it now what's going to
happen to nuclear non-proliferation
because we've told all our NATO members
and Japan and so many countries we will
protect you with our nuclear umbrella
and it's not believable it's never been
credible and this will prove that it's
not credible that we will not use
nuclear weapons most likely even to
defend our allies in Ukraine you know
thus far is not a NATO member not an
ally we have to defend I've been saying
uh basically this for a while and I've
had other people argue people argue with
me that I said mutually assured
destruction is just that's not true this
idea that I suppose the idea is if if
Russia decides to Nuke DC then the U.S
will fire back in Moscow or something
like that but what I was saying is that
this idea that the use of nuclear
weapons in general results in everyone
just firing nukes and blowing everybody
up in fact there's one really obvious
reason why NATO will not nuke back in
the war the wars in Ukraine Russia has
invaded the Eastern region
Putin can fire nukes into Ukraine
anywhere he wants and causes much damage
as he wants because he's trying to take
it NATO does not want to destroy Ukraine
they're trying to push Russia out so
theoretically if Russia moves too far
into Ukraine say in the Eastern region
then maybe they'll use nukes there but
they'd be effectively losing by doing it
cutting off their nose to spite their
face well a couple things I worry about
here is that we're in a desperate
situation I I think the Russians in some
instances are desperate I think the
ukrainians are also desperate here and
they know that that they're facing a lot
of very tough odds here they have a lot
of support but at the end of the day
Russia still has a lot more manpower
Russia still has a lot more bullets even
though there's a lot of countries
selling them bullets Germany has a
bullet shortage I think this is more
significant than we're uh there that
that of course is not being talked about
here I I think in this desperation we
shouldn't rule out the possibility of
someone staging an attack or staging an
incident that would escalate this
situation possibly get other countries
involved here right now we have Belarus
do a joint military task force with
Russia they're mobilizing on the
Ukrainian border they've been mobilizing
for a couple months now but I think
we're in a situation where the the
history of the previous world wars is
rhyming and and what happened then was
other countries got involved and I I
think there's a big possibility that
Ukraine in their desperation or Russia
in their desperation could stage an
event that could be the galvanizing
event that could launch a bigger
conflict here that would move Beyond
this proxy war between Russia and the
United States do you think that's a
possibility yeah it's absolutely true
that that could happen but you know
people like to make comparisons back in
history as you mentioned back to World
War II and you know Hitler didn't have
nuclear weapons nor did they have
biological weapons or the ability to
release them in the United States Putin
does so you got a corner dog a guy who's
desperate wants to retain power and we
should not be provoking him I'm glad to
support Ukraine if we can but we should
not be pushing Russia and Putin in the
desperate man into a situation where he
feels like the only way I'm going to
stay alive and stay in power is to knock
the U.S and Western European support out
of Ukraine and I do that either with
escalating with nuclear weapons which is
really a risky for me because they could
eventually retaliate with nuclear
weapons against me or I could be smart
about it and just release a biological
agent that starts a horrible pandemic in
the U.S and Western I think you do the
latter now now I just want to talk about
this biological agent because you know
you bring it up a couple times in the
1957 to 1958 avian flu pandemic that
killed two million people and they say
it's not as effective as a bio weapon
because the host usually dies and
transmission is less likely when we have
such a very strong virus do you have any
counter evidence or is there a new type
of thing that you know about from your
work and intelligence that that says
that this is going to be different than
the 1957-1958 avian flute sure that's a
very low lethality of ours I mean it's
worse than avian flu but you're talking
about like one percent lethality so look
at that of the the so-called misnamed
Spanish Flu back at the end of World War
One 1919 1920 time frame that was like a
1.5 percent lethality rate avian flu is
way less not I'm sorry even flusueva I'm
sorry covid-19 is like way you know it's
.001 lethality very very low but avian
flu as I said a 60 lethal now when you
modify it you may get a different
lethality rate it may be a lot lower it
may be higher I don't know you're
changing the virus yeah but the question
I have is if people are getting it and
dying right away the virus won't spread
as fast correct uh viruses generally
it's better for them not to be too
highly lethal you kill off all your
hosts but it's well it's really simple I
mean gain of function research you get
you get a virus you get something as
lethal as an avian flu but you engineer
it to have a two-week delay in ons in
symptoms that's the worst that's the
third thing I mean I've been talking
about transmissibility and lethality but
Tim you just brought up the third really
bad thing if it's got a latency period
where I'm contagious this I'm spreading
the virus but I don't have any symptoms
yet then you're really really screwed
over we were talking about this last
week that you know look nuclear weapons
the Advent of which was over 80 years
ago you get this report published in
1938 I can't remember who who shot it
out is that will mentioned that 1938 on
the the scientific paper on fission and
then all of a sudden everybody gets the
idea like you could make a bomb with
that and then finally we did and what
was uh what was the um there was a fat
man wasn't like a 15 kiloton bomb or
something like that what's the name of
one of those was fat man they're both
about 15 20 kilotons
15 to 20 kilotons nothing compared to
the nukes that they currently have today
especially with mervs when they have
multiple Warheads
but bringing that up I mean this is old
technology you'd have to imagine they've
developed different and new capabilities
in Modern Warfare that we don't know
about and we won't know about until they
do I think Fair Point biological weapons
seems to be the route to take yeah who
knows what Peter dazek and the CIA are
doing with Echo Health Alliance with Dr
Falcon's funding still as they got
funded again but but I think there's
also another important aspect you know
viruses usually don't spread well
without any kind of symptoms sneeze and
coughing is how viruses usually spread
if they develop something new I don't
know but uh this would be end of the
world you you launch a bio weapon it's
going to affect everyone so you got it
through the food supply covet was found
in ice cream and it can live in animal
fat you gotta watch out for food just
from my assessment my research I do
think smaller escalations more attacks
on on the infrastructure in Ukraine and
I think you know a bigger all-out war
and and potential false flags are more
of a possibility than buy weapons from
my perspective in my opinion yeah yeah
but hold on we're not like I I don't
know if this is what you're saying but
my view is not that Putin right now is
just like a flu no he goes with
artillery goes nuclear artillery he goes
tactical nukes
in the event of total desperation when
with U.S involvement getting too heavy
and his conventional method's not
working and his escalation not working I
think I would agree that someone maybe
it's Putin maybe it's not someone's
going to try and and knock out the US
economy either by uh you know well I
would assume a a clever way to hit the
United States clandestine as you
mentioned is a bio weapon yes and
remember back in March um the Russians
were putting out propaganda saying hey
the U.S has these biological weapons
programs in the Ukraine and why in the
world were they doing it it made no
sense but they were talking about gain
of function research and allege that we
were doing bio weapons work with the
ukrainians this was going on in March of
this with ukrainians correct so he was
trying to lay the pretext of in my you
know why would he do that the only
logical reason for the Russians to do
that is because that they're trying to
set the stage for saying hey these
biological weapons are coming out it
ain't us it's the U.S and the ukrainians
releasing it and so and we were
concerned about that a lot it was
written on that and well pushed back
saying hey this is nonsense but why
wouldn't the US be doing it why wouldn't
we do we want building bio labs to make
uh weapons well we signed the treaties
saying we would not use biological
weapons and warfare and I think and I
think we're we're following that but you
know I think it's very probable that
Trump could do that and he could be
doing it tomorrow well if you remember
in Ukraine the U.S corporate media and
political establishment first said
there's no bio weapons there's no bio
lab facilities in Ukraine and then the
Secretary of State under assistant
secretary came out and said uh there's
medical facilities in Ukraine we've got
to get to immediately before the
Russians get to and everyone's like yeah
we're doing research there what kind of
research gain of function research
trying to take a virus and make it the
most lethal the most dangerous virus
that we can in the name of science even
though many scientists argued that there
hasn't been any gain of function done
for any kind of scientific discovery but
predominantly done to uh have bio
weapons out there so when you look at
you know the United States uh Barack
Obama banned Gano function research
Donald Trump for some reason allowed it
to happen and that's when Dr fauci Peter
dazek Echo Health Alliance went to Wuhan
China and then started to do the covid
back coronavirus research there now
they're doing it again under Joe Biden
but now they're doing it in Myanmar Laos
in Vietnam again Peter dazek doing gain
of function research on covid
coronavirus I don't know if you've heard
of these but but this is something
eye-opening and of course there was also
similar gain of function research being
done in Ukraine as well well let me for
a second defend the gain of function
research as I've already you know
attacked it but the reason we do it is
is also avian flu is naturally mutating
all the time every virus does and
biologists have been warning us for a
long time now Congressional testimony
even saying avian flu will probably
mutate to be human human transmissible
even if humans aren't screwing around
with it trying to deliberately do that
so that's why we're doing the gain of
function research on the avian flu it is
eventually going to develop I mean swine
flu comes to pigs develops mutates but
we're not talking about that what's
going to happen so they're doing the
gain of function research because we
want to have a human human transmissible
form of avian flu now so we can develop
vaccines for it that's why they're doing
it that's a legitimate reason that could
I could understand the argument for but
that's not what they're doing they're
doing coronavirus bat research that has
no probability of ever uh realizing in
real life because of natural
circumstances right thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there